25 n'empêche pas des élections
simplement c'est madrid qui peut imposer
les élections et il se dit qu'il a plus
de chances de dison de moins les perdre
si elles sont imposés par madrid c'est à
dire la seule carte qu'il est faux bien
rare que ce référendum est assez
largement un échec parce que il ya quand
même 60 % des catalans qui n'ont pas dit
oui à l'indépendance qui ne sont pas
allés voter ou qui ont tous sont allés
voter non ouais mais il ya 80% des
catalans qui soutenait l'idée d'un
référendum et le référendum 90% des
personnes ont dit oui à l'indépendance
je répète peut-être mais il ya 60% des
catalans qui ne sont pas allés voter
pour l'indépendance ce qui est dans un
contexte de confrontation avec le
pouvoir central le cycle l'idée de
l'indépendance est aujourd'hui en
catalogue minoritaires donc par rapport
à ça
la seule carte qui soit bonne pour lui
c'est quand le pouvoir central se durcit
ça a été quand ils ont été trop
répressif avec le premier week-end et
c'est maintenant si les élections sont
des élections imposé par madrid on
pourra dire voilà c'est le train arrière
de place et donc c'est la seule façon de
limiter la casse après un référendum
perdu si on voit ça de loin moi je vous
dis au risque de continuer à avoir votre
arithmétique en objections que
fondamentalement c'est un référendum
perdu les référendums gagner sont sur
des questions celle là comme celle-ci
décisifs sont des vraies femmes à forte
participation et fort résultat là c'est
fort résultat mais très faible
participation
donc une fois qu'on a perdu le
référendum ça devient très difficile de
trouver des sorties de secours qui vous
met fasse pas qui vous déshabille pas
intégralement est donc renvoyé la balle
à chaque fois sur madrid de gazon avec
si c'est vrai qu'il le fait à chaque
fois mais on sait ce qui peut faire de
moins mauvais compte tenu de la
faiblesse dans laquelle ils se pensent
ça commence